before this video begins a very epic
announcement that's right everybody
Origin PC sponsor everyone say it with
me
loud and clear Origin PC neuro Origin PC
neuron desktop it's a computer that I
have look how that goes in the bar look
at this look at this baby this is the
computer I have but they have announced
newer on RTS which of course stands for
really tight snowball no that was a joke
it's called real-time shipping as cool
as real-time shipping sounds it's ready
to ship real-time shipping would be cool
though they sell for only 1499
but there's limited inventory you gotta
act fast
ok the neuron RTS has an NVIDIA GeForce
r-tx 26 C GPU and a 6 core professor
that means you can perfectly game
perfectly stream perfectly watch memes
and pretend that you have no any idea
what any of this means
I mean I can't even pretend clearly what
are you some sort of loser that don't
play games on ultra graphics ha pathetic
it's of course the latest graphics
technology ok real-time ray tracing for
lifelike lighting in such games like
metro Exodus and DL SS with improved
performance and fps I know what fps
means ok guys
but wait that's not it you also have
three games including and thanks to this
little baby you can easily upgrade it
during the future as well it's very
easily upgradeable you will also get
lifetime tech support
in the u.s. available 24/7 365 days a
year baby you need help with your
computer on Christmas we got you baby
but that's not it what
also giving one away that's right you
guys get bread as well check out the
link in description for dear way way
info that's it for me for now enjoy the
video smack like and subscribe and epic
one man that is truly holy and holds a
special place in my heart
I think of neoprene and no one else
sorry Marcia but Neil Breen takes my
heart
now who is Neil Breen you ask well hi
thanks for checking out my crowdfunding
site my name is Neil Breen I'm a
filmmaker I'm in the process of
producing my fourth legitimate feature
film Neil breeding is a legitimate
filmmaker and I made videos on his
previous work in the past which is
nothing short of oscar-worthy
performance wife's director Weiss
everything you've committed suicide oh I
can't help you out of this one Jim we've
all we've been through I can't pull you
out of this one
can't pull you out of this one what can
I say Neil is the bass I love this
background that he chose it says so much
and so little at the same time which is
actually a great way to describe his
film now a couple a couple of days ago
me and some friends in Brighton we
watched it another one of his films one
of his older work called the double down
now why don't we double down together
and go through this masterpiece
Neal Breen psychological thriller Double
Down it's a masterpiece I'm not gonna
lie it's a little light it's a little
hard to sit through there are some
moments I'm questioning why I watch this
film but there are those golden moments
and that's what we're gonna focus on
today's so the film starts up with this
lovely footage of clouds and you think
wow this actually looks pretty great I
like the music it's made by Neal Green
we don't know what Neal brain has done
but we know that he is involved in this
field there's now I know what you're
asking yourself will there be another
Neal green text on the screen please I
need to see more Neal brief text on the
screen don't worry it is coming there's
got to be patient because this video
because this film has to be in our 30
minutes so that it can be quite where
producers writen and directed by Neil
brain incredible actually like this
shots I don't I can't complain too much
it goes through this I could thank
beautiful there he is
look at those sideburns Aaron Brown
Aaron I always thought I was doing the
right thing and preparing for life I was
the first in my class in college and
computers okay all you need to know
about this character literally you don't
need to know anything besides say he's a
hacker
he's a genius I don't know he's there's
a lot of things okay perhaps most
importantly he enjoys eating tuna at
Akane's I don't need much to live on
anymore
I just eat tuna out of the can and live
in the car
you know for being a genius he's really
bad at eating tuna while driving Oh Neil
oh that was close
that was real close this is why you
never eat tuna out of a can while
driving please let this be a learning
lesson for all of you out there now
mercenary for any nation it's gonna be a
lot of shots I'm not gonna lie there's
gonna be a lot of shots of Neil Breen
running through rocks and if that's not
your cup of tea then then you're just a
hater
and this movie isn't for you so you can
just back away okay you can just get
away from here we ain't got time for
this
I want to watch Neil breathe remove my
life one look at that and look at that
claim absolutely incredible or get he
married you know as a passionate fan of
Neil Breen's work there is a car there
are a couple current beams one of them
being an excessive use of laptops Neil
Breen loves to use laptops why use one
laptop when he's can use two laps down
to assess and why use one phone and
break you can use two phones
simultaneously no one abuses laptops
like Neil Breen don't know nail yeah
don't do it Neil don't do it god damn it
me a look first book me don't hit that
book with them god damn can't wait any
longer I don't care how angry you are go
god damn e you don't don't not again my
god not it
someone stop this man I know you're
upset it has a deeper meaning I'm just
really glad that laptop has made it an
apparent here as well
satellite dishes five laptops six oh
he's got five laptops six oh there are
very dangerous Wars going on that will
never end he's talking about t-series
vs. PewDiePie that's right I snuck that
one in there so Neil Green is basically
like an undercover agent type of really
hard to explain
Neil brain character is like a super
rogue agent to secret war underground
desert-dwelling
character I disappear he can disappear
home and he also has a force field which
is pretty much filled with cause for
shield sir if an intruder the force
shield will cause death if an intruder
draws near just letting you guys know
that that's the thing that Neil Breen
has this is important for the plot and
story no it isn't but that is not
necessary in Neil Breen's films okay you
just don't understand three laptops at
the same time port or truth
how many laptops do you use at the same
time huh one two threes but there's no
waiver is that way it's therefore there
is far own but there is for laptops I
didn't see the fourth one my mind sorry
guys I gotta rewrite this review so now
we have more shots of neo brain running
around in the desert an excellent
climber and an excellent athleticism but
he's about to find something in these
rocks now place your bets in the
comments please what do you think Neil
brain is gonna find in the rocks
the winner gets gets to smash like on
this video what is he finding
another laptop everyone the fifth laptop
makes this appearance
yep that's a laptop yep
confirmed it is in fact a laptop
remember we were seven and it was love
at first sight we loved each other since
because you have matching pants is that
why Neal there he is again with the
laptops now to be clear here we are 17
minutes into the film and we haven't
seen or heard any dialogue whatsoever
it's just been nothing but this and Neal
Breen talking over the footage there was
an error in the calculation okay all
right but let's go to the best fit in my
opinion of the entire film it starts off
with the footage of a very public pool
as you can see here then cut to Neal
brain beam naked in this pool with naked
lady I love you will you marry me yes
yes yes I will marry
you can tell she really feels strongly
about this clip now I definitely want to
be in this shot okay I guess what I want
to show myself as much as possible I'm
so happy I can't wait to be your wife o
Neill B nail breathe that's a laser
we'll always be together
I need to know that watch out Neal
breathe how does she not see the laser
it is possible anything's possible
thank you watches jeez
is it me or is it hot in here god damn
that was sexy ah ah
I cannot recreate that fantastic sound
only one man jeez that is the shriek of
pure agony now if you thought this whole
scenario was obscure enough I guess we
it gets a spear
okay sure oh not the flower
okay cut to her then wait for it
[Music]
yes thank you very much Neil Breen for
that immaculate shot beautiful fantastic
art and he's gone oh okay there he is
I find myself waking up on the ground PJ
pointed out this when we watched at it
it's like we see him waking up from the
ground we don't need him I'm sorry Nia I
don't think what he need him pointing
out that he's waking up from the ground
as much as I love the soothing sound of
Neil Greene's buttery voice just just a
thought the whole plot of the film kind
of sounds like Neil Greene's personal
thoughts I don't know how to explain it
but showing this I'm always amazed that
how governments all over the world are
so concerned about nuclear missiles and
nuclear bombs and all the very expensive
and secret technology involved
the reality is that chemical and
biological weapons can be much more
destructive to societies and economies
in nuclear weapons all right Alex Jones
all right thank you appreciate it
oh he's laying on the ground again
now wait what just happened did he wake
up or did he find himself waking up in
the ground is that what happened Neil
you're not explaining what's going on
just got a check if pretty pie stone
winning over t-series okay they're fine
I've received their directions now
introducing the greatest character of
all time Neil Breen is walking through
the desert in the middle of nowhere and
he stumbles upon none other than desert
Santa desert Santa everyone he sits in
the desert I don't know what desert
Santa does now unfortunately don't get
too attached to desert Santa I know as I
love him dearly as well but deserts
ain't that the old man you don't look
like a tourist to me then don't point
your gun at him Neil brain its desert
Santa
where does he go in that's some fine
climbing meal
what is desert Santa gonna do follow him
there's no way desert Santa can follow
him that was some way too tricky of a
path no one could ever do that no one
has to parkour skills to follow neoprene
in the desert
Neal Breen knows this of course no no it
was a goddamn me he shouldn't have tried
to follow neoprene the path was too
strict he got outplayed desert Santa
outplayed son I was drawn to him I felt
I knew his spirit now this is actually a
love story between Neal and desert Santa
which is quite tear breaking the blood
is gone from his head but he's still
dying what are you saying deserts ain't
him
lend me your wisdom he gave him what did
he gave him
[Music]
the desert santa stone
that's a nice shot and that's a nice
Barrett you just just put some rock over
him he'll be fine
he gets he's alive he's just sleeping in
his rocker babe
then we have Neela visiting his parents
I guess I don't I don't know what's
happening here I like this I like this
shot it's kind of aesthetic dad it's
like a good wallpaper we are filled with
love and we are at peace well that's
nice
so apparently even if you're dead you
can still not properly walk in it still
hurts to walk on gravel and stone how
about that hey that just looks painful
all that we do is drive around and get
caught up in spectacular car chases and
dude buildings blowing up and wild
gunfire and so on that only happens in
the movies and on TV it really doesn't
happen in real life in a real life
everything we do is done very silently
undercover and electronically the public
never knows what we're doing it's all
done in very very secret ways I'm so
water please
can I have some water please okay yes
speaking of Secrets there is one I want
to share with you my daughter Megan was
just diagnosed with brain cancer no no
I'm sorry
that sucks what a lovely Miam looks
delicious
she's got brain cancer so he's putting
his hand on her brain now back to more
footage of Neil Breen climbing my
favorite footage I could watch this my
entire life look at things look at those
moves grab the rock oh no no I grabbed
it anyway that helped that helped him on
the line oh no it didn't you grab
another Rock Neil he got the rock
fantastic
is he gonna make it up he made it up no
one else can do that it's me give me the
president contact has been out what in
that what is happening at this point I
don't really know what happens in the
middle of the film it's one big blur to
be honest and we're just gonna we're
just gonna skip let's move away from the
cars they may be wired
watch this extremely smooth oh sorry
that's okay
no damage there's a bug device on the
car now how are you I don't really know
what's going on to be honest I don't I
like the bit where nothing happened and
it didn't make any sense this is the
Metal Gear Solid play
what does that even mean so Neal green
drugs this couple kills the guy and when
the lady wakes up this is what he has to
say
[Music]
we're in Las Vegas last night we went to
the club danced a lot drank a lot
laughed a lot and had sex out by the
fountains then we went down to the strip
and we got married
hey this is Las Vegas baby
imagine you wake up you don't know where
you are
Neil brain shows up and says last night
we drank a lot
we had sex by the fountains we laughed a
lot and then we went down to the strip
and got married
hey Las Vegas baby what do you do what
would you do if this happened to you
what we're married
then literally ten seconds later get out
get out the marriage is over
marriage is over
this Carla had a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to marry neoprene and it
only lasted five seconds gosh damn it
ten seconds well at least you
experienced those 10 seconds of pure joy
and bliss and love I'm pretty sure Neil
isn't supposed to need that skull but I
like the touch anyway
Hey look it's more Neil running in the
desert Jess look at him go look at him
go
oh excuse me contact literally literally
me when I accidentally bump into someone
oh excuse me contact so relatable I
think that's why I like his films
they're just really able another
reoccurring theme in needle spoons that
Ferraris that's right is that the sake
no it's the same Ferrari I can't help
you out of this one Jim
he just took Jim's Ferrari he loved that
car I don't know if there's any point of
me explaining what's going on I think
it's better to just appreciate these
these golden moments like this one for
example holy [ __ ] it's him yeah it's him
how can that be how can that be possible
[Music]
I was wondering what happened to all the
tuna cans
does he recycle them or does he just
have a cardboard box in his trunk
where he keeps all the tuna cans and I'm
just really glad that we finally had the
answer what happens to all the tuna cans
Neil green leaves no questions
unanswered now of course in the end we
get to see one of the best Neil green
running
and screaming okay go Nia
run like the wind nut run like you've
never run before
[Music]
how long is this how long is this gonna
keep okay so the movie ends with Neil
green walking away with nothing
his girl
[Music]
or nothing
I don't know but the most important part
of the end is actually the credits
because we have directed by neil brief
musical director Neil green editor Neil
pre production designer Neil Bri
production manager Neil green casting
Neil green and most importantly lighting
none makeup and hair none locations Neil
bridge catering Neil Breen Erin brand
Neil cream I always wondered who does
the lighting in this video it's
impeccable
who is this none and how do they do it
so greatly so that was double down
everyone hope you guys enjoyed I'm gonna
leave a link you can support Neil
breeding and buy his films in the
description and check them out yourself
because they are really something to
admire and appreciate thank you guys for
watching this video if you enjoyed smash
like let me know if you like this type
of stuff and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]